[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est évidemment une immense
satisfaction parce que ça a été
ces huit derniers mois très difficile
très difficile parce qu'on a quand même
été confronté à une campagne
particulièrement violente
et puis parce que en même temps il a
fallu gérer comme tout le monde mais
cette crise sanitaire
donc aujourd'hui j'ai un profond
soulagement parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'on peut continuer un travail qui est
qui est important et qui doit être
accomplie et puis la portée et l'ampleur
du score
ça donne une grande confiance et surtout
ça donne l'élan d'être porté par par
notre base
il va falloir comment qu'on regarde
comment on va sortir de cette crise et
quelles sont les conséquences pour pour
nous pour notre sport et après ces
quatre années exaltantes et surtout sur
le territoire ici on va aller vers les
jeux olympiques de paris 2024 il y aura
tokyo quand même cette année donc sur le
plan sportif très dense pour nous on a
vraiment à réussir notre transformation
économique et puis presque culturelle de
notre fédération
au regard de la montée en puissance du
vélo dans notre société donc les
chantiers sont vraiment passionnant et
je le qualifierais plutôt comme une
commune olympiade où il faut pas manquer
la fenêtre de tir mais où ça va être
très stimulant on a un objectif pour
tokyo qui était celui de 2020 qu'on
maintient en 2021 qui est officiel qui
est un objectif de 6 médailles c'est un
objectif que j'avais fixé au début de la
précédente olympiades qui ambitieux très
ambitieux mais on y va a crânement